This video is sponsored by Book Walker.
♫ Idols - Suppy ♫
Well, we've reached the end of 2019 and once again we get to look back on another year of anime.
We got to see all kinds of shows in all shapes and forms, so that begs the question:
What are you gonna remember 2019 for?
2019 has somehow equaled or maybe even eclipsed the monster year that was 2018.
Anime is good now, it's just good,
and with more of it than ever before. we have not been struggling for choices.
We've had the good, the bad, the ugly, and just the plain weird,
so as we take a look back at what we watched, and probably what we missed,
let's see how anime signed itself off for this decade.
This is...
Anime in 2019.
I'm gonna be honest with you,
even I had trouble keeping up with all the anime coming out last year,
and I feel that's just kind of the norm nowadays.
So instead of trying to cover everything, I'm just gonna keep it to my personal favorite things,
ending it on my anime of the year.
But I'll do my best to talk about everything that mattered to me and made waves in our community,
and looking back for a place to start in 2019,
there was one thing we kept having to ask ourselves over and over again.
Are you excited for more isekai next season?
"No, hehehehe, no not another one."
"You're joking, not another one!"
One of these days, I'll get to look back on a year of anime and think to myself,
"Man,
there was a reasonably conservative amount of isekai this time."
This year wasn't one of them.
Somehow the number doesn't seem to be decreasing but increasing.
Every time, I say to myself,
"Surely we can't get even more isekai next year."
No. That is a trap.
Don't say it.
As soon as you do, some unsuspecting victim tries to cross the road
and truck-kun claims another life and nobody can stop it.
So I'm just gonna stop doing it.
I'm not going to think about it.
I'm just not going to say it anymore.
Alright?
And this isn't even a dig at the genre,
this year we saw more variation than the usual power fantasy affair that we're used to.
Cautious Hero,
Kemono Michi,
and Ascendance of a Bookworm
all look genuinely good and different.
I kind of just hit my isekai quota and haven't gotten around to watching them yet.
But there were a lot of others I did enjoy.
Shield Hero kicked off the year proving that all it takes to make a community collectively
forget about years worth of built-up isekai fatigue
was one raccoon girl and an angry boy.
The series sported easily the most hatable villain of the year, that built up to a climax
*clapping*
so satisfying the only thing that was actually rising was the revenge boner that could be felt community-wide.
*more clapping*
My only real problem was with how cheaply Naofumi was built up
by essentially bringing everyone else down.
Sure you're rooting for Naofumi, but he's held up as being the only competent character
by making everyone but him and his party an absolute fucking useless idiot.
♫ Rise - MADKID ♫
So it's really a no-brainer that you'd end up cheering for him
because he's the only one that seems to have half a fucking brain cell.
*Intense Shield Hero vibes*
♫ OH OH OH OH OHHH OH OH ♫
Still looking forward to season two and three though.
Sword Art Online has gotten to the point where I just genuinely enjoy it for what it is.
This is just fun popcorn entertainment and exactly why I enjoy isekai in the first place,
though I do find it funny that all my favorite parts of Sword Art Online
have conveniently come when Kirito is out of the picture.
Alice taking on the main role has been a welcome change
and there have been criticism that she's just a ripoff from Saber from Fate,
but come on guys.
I mean she may look like Saber,
talk like Saber,
act like Saber,
fight like Saber,
have very similar looking powers as Saber,
but she's also..
a tsundere.
So I don't see how she can be a ripoff
(when she's quite clearly an upgrade).
Kenja no Mago was an isekai.
That's pretty much all I remember despite actually finishing it.
Of course isekai's still isekai and there was plenty of trash which I'll get back to later,
but for me, the surprise of the year was Isekai Quartet, 'cause I enjoyed it way more than I anticipated.
I thought I would get bored after two episodes,
but the character writing and banter was so on point that it never got old.
We've gotten to the point where we can just put a bunch of isekai characters in an isekai world
and have them talk about isekai stuff and it's just entertaining.
This is partly because it just kind of felt like an episode of KonoSuba with an extended cast,
which is probably why I enjoyed it so much.
And I'm just glad that we finally have our own
Avenger-kai's.
They may not be able to avenge the world, but you can be damn sure they'll reincarnate into another one.
Overall I think the moral of this year is that isekai is here to stay and is still definitely thriving,
and that's fine because you know what?
*Takes a breath*
Surely, we can't get EVEN MORE isekai next year.
*A faint NOO that grows*
♫ The Moon [8-Version] - Capcom ♫
MC: "Nanto-"
Subaru: "Ore wa Emilia-"
*cries while waiting*
Shin: "Sore de-"
*Terrified gasp*
[Quivering]
He had to say it.
*CRASH*
[Trembling, truly terrified]
He had to say it!
Akihito: "Ora ora ~"
When I think of the music that came out of anime in 2019, what comes to mind is
*bad piano playing*
Nope.
Wait, I- I got it.
Yosemite Sam: "Oooh ya STUPID rabbit!"
"Like this!"
*Giorno's theme*
I don't have much to say about the OST's of this year.
Sure there were singular songs and tracks that stood out:
Giorno's theme,
Isabella's lullaby,
that track from that scene in Demon Slayer.
Shout out to my boy Kevin Penkin for looking at your typical anime fantasy setting and thinking,
"You know what this needs?"
"Sexy..."
"..Isekai..."
"...saxophone."
♫ OhKami - Kevin Penkin ♫
But unlike previous years, there weren't any soundtracks as a whole that really stood out.
That is of course until I realized the best anime music of the year was stuck behind Netflix jail.
One of them was Beastars, but the other one gives me the opportunity to talk about..
♫ The Loneliest Girl - Carole & Tuesday
(Vo. Nai Br.XX & Celeina Ann) ♫
Carole and Tuesday didn't just give us an OST, it just straight-up gave us several albums worth of music.
The sheer amount of songs on display here in all different genres is absolutely insane.
You've got stuff like EDM, metal, Carole and Tuesday's simpler acoustic sound,
whatever genre this fits into, and of course classic pop.
And all that was just a single episode.
While in most music anime, the show will normally centre around some musicians
building up to their next big performance, their next big song,
which if we're lucky will happen maybe every three [or] four episodes,
Carole and Tuesday is just here casually debuting at least one new song every episode.
At least, one.
Most of the time we're getting two, three or four, coming from the various characters on display,
not forgetting other miscellaneous things, like,
I don't know,
actual background music,
the OP's, the ED's,
and even references to the classical music of its setting in the future.
Random character: "My mother passed away not that long ago."
"I'm singing a song she often sang to me when I was young."
*EXTREMLY deep breath*
T/N: Sounds that can only be described as jaw-dropping
I don't think there's been another anime that's come close to the amount of music in this show,
and I realize when watching this how much of a core element music is in all of Shinichiro Watanabe's works.
Because this entire show felt like his personal love letter to music itself.
And I don't think anyone else would have been able to get so many talented artists from all over the world
to help provide the music for a single anime.
If the writing had been tighter, this had the potential to be an absolute masterpiece.
But, as it stands it is simply a GOOD show with by far the most impressive music production
any anime has ever seen,
and maybe will ever get.
'Cause I don't man, I don't see how any show will ever top the likes of this.
♫ Galactic Mermaid - Mermaid Sisters
(Vo. Yuuri Kuriyama) ♫
♫ FUCKING BULLSHIT ♫
*clears throat*
Speaking of which,
♫ FUCKING BULLSHIT ♫
♫ Holy shit oh fucker ♫
If we're going through the best of anime, we also can't forget the best of the worst we saw,
so let's do the rundown of what we got to experience this year.
A lot of bullshit isekai,
a lot of softcore hentai,
not enough culture.
Number of anime girls this year who asks someone to drink their urine.
Two!
Bear Grylls: "This brings back good memories."
Number of anime girls who saw a suppository get shoved up their ass this year.
"How you going in?"
"Rectally."
ALSO two!
*Squealing*
Let's see what magical girls got up to this year.
"M A G I C A L  S P A N K I N G!"
Let's forget what magical girls got up to this year.
How about shows that acted as visual bleach for the eyes?
W'z kicked things off with an equally ugly sequel to Hand Shakers absolutely nobody asked for.
Seven Deadly Sins ended the year off with one of the most highly anticipated fights of the series,
Meliodas vs. Escanor,
a fight so hyped up by fans that Studio Deen tried to do it justice by staying faithful to the franchise
and adapted it using only seven deadly frames of animation.
Mister Nobunaga's Young Bride gave us an anime about a loli attempting to convince a fully grown man
"POLICE! HELP!"
"POLICE!"
Mister Nobunaga's Young Bride gave us an anime about a loli attempting to convince a fully grown man
"HELP!"
"POLICE!"
to get married to her and consummate it.
"POLICE!!"
That's it.
That's the plot of the show.
"HELLLP!!"
"HEEEEL-"
The worst CG award went to Arifureta, who also gave us The Rising of the Ghoul Hero,
the off-brand Christmas present some mum probably gave to the poor kid who asked for Shield Hero,
featuring another edgy protagonist teaming up with a 300 year old demon loli
with a romantic subplot they were totally gonna dangle in front of us.
Heheha.
*gasp*
Oh.
"POLICE!"
And of course, there were the two dumpster fires this year that burned so brightly
I couldn't keep my eyes off them.
I watched Domestic Girlfriend with my girlfriend once...
She's my stepsister now.
Domestic Girlfriend is what happens when you take a typical harem romance anime
and then try to do a full 100% degeneracy speedrun and succeed.
A show with so much spice you have to refer to the Scoville scale when rating it.
Documenting the case of a protagonist who finally dropped the mister and got with his sister,
using a secret technique never before seen in anime.
"Hey wanna be my girlfriend?"
"But we can't, we're brother and sister!"
"No please, I incest."
"Okay."
*Machine gun slurping SFX*
I don't even know why YouTube demonetized my review of this,
I thought Domestic Girlfriend was the epitome of family-friendly content.
Then finally we had Assassins Pride,
commonly referred to as,
M'lady Battle Angel.
A plot that was written like a fan fiction of a fan fiction of an anime,
that didn't actually have a better love story than Twilight.
Meet Kufa Vampir, son of a twisted relationship between a vampire and a fedora.
Full-time loli magnet.
"POLICE!"
Knock knock,
what's this?
A perfectly suitable romantic interest who's in love with you and also a similar age?
What are you?
Legal!?
This is Kufa Vampir.
"POLICE!"
The FBI have to check if they're on the Kufa Vampir registry.
When Chris Hanson tells him to take a seat,
HE'S ALREADY SITTING DOWN!
And of course, he's the only man who could possibly cap off this year of glorious trash.
"POLICE!"
♫ Fucking piece of shit ♫
"HEEEEELLLP!"
♫ Oh yeah! ♫
♫ Doot doot doot doot ♫
"HEEEEELLLP!"
♫ Fuck. ♫
This year had a strong showing from slice-of-life and romance,
not just giving titles that were solid additions to the
pre-established formula,
but also ones that broke the mold and did something new.
Oresuki did to harem what KonoSuba had done for isekai,
Hensuki gave us a bunch of new kinks just so it could shame us later on,
Fruits Basket: Brotherhood was a thing I still need to finish,
*clears throat*
like another certain Brotherhood...
People are terrified right now at the implication of the World War Season 3 teaser that just got released,
forgetting that Quintessential Quintuplets has already started World War 5 in 2019,
and many of us have already been drafted.
Senko-san was ASMR for the eyes,
by giving us a middle-aged salaryman mastering the forbidden technique of
DUAL WIELDING HEAD PATS
against some innocent boomer lolis
in what my depression has categorized as an Avengers level threat.
But if I had to talk about the shows that really had an effect on me,
the first one that comes to mind would have to be Kaguya-sama...
♫ Love Dramatic - Mayasaki Suzuki feat. Rikka Ihara ♫
Gigguk: Oh love me mister ♪
♪ Hey mister ♪
In one of the most refreshing takes of the romantic comedy genre I've seen in a while.
The mix of the absurd, over-the-top mind games in the typical harem romance situations
was a premise that continued to be hilarious throughout, and before I knew it,
I was actually heavily invested in these two characters getting together.
I think there was another reason to watch a show, but um,
*clicks tongue* uhhh,
I just can't remember what it was right now...
*Chika noises synced to Beethoven*
♫ Ode to Joy - Beethoven ♫
Ah of course, how could I forget.
Ishigami best girl.
*Chika squeal*
O Maidens in Your Savage Season was probably my overlooked gem of the year
in one of the most hilariously accurate portrayals of puberty I've seen in anime.
It's rare that you get to see the topic of sex tackled as the awkward, uncomfortable mess that it is
when you first discovered it and started thinking about it.
You know that one embarrassing sex story everyone seems to have as a teenager
that is hilarious to tell but kind of makes you want to die inside when you remember it?
That is it.
That is the show.
How Heavy Are the Dumbbells You Lift? finally gave us cute girls do lifting
in an anime so alpha not even tyler1 can come close to even matching it.
*scream*
*macho noises*
in an anime so alpha not even tyler1 can come close to even matching it.
*Chika squeal*
While this might not be the greatest anime of the year,
it certainly had one of the biggest real-life effects on me,
because I don't want to admit that I'm THAT degenerate weeb who got motivated to join a gym
'cause I saw some cute anime girls doing it, but...
*sigh*
I'm that degenerate weeb who got motivated to join the gym because I saw some cute anime girls doing it,
which makes me think,
"What's next for cute anime girls?"
Cute girls do basic daily hygiene?
Cute girls do filling out your annual tax return?
Cute girls do interacting with cute girls in real life?
Whatever it is, I think we finally figured out the end goal of all moe shows:
Cute girls do transforming weebs into functional members of society.
And then, there was my personal favorite high school drama of the year.
I came in to Beastars knowing nothing,
ready to meme the shit out of it,
and I came out with one of my favorite anime of the year.
This feels like one of the most unique series in recent memory,
and no, it's not because the characters are walking furry baits.
This doesn't feel like your typical glossy anime.
In fact, it doesn't feel like anime at all.
It gives off the vibe of an Oscar-nominated film or a highly acclaimed stage play,
with the combination of some of the best voice acting performances you can find all year,
and fantastic direction that was one of the only times in my life that had me saying,
"Man..."
"I'm really glad this anime's in 3D."
It's the story of a murder mystery,
an unequal society dominated by the strong,
a man driven to obsession to be THE image of the perfect star,
and also a touching love story between
a literal virgin and actual chad.
The world of Beastars is one that draws you in and sells you on these characters.
It deeply immerses you, then sells you on pure drama and emotion.
[Legosi beating the shit out of him]
[Oh shit]
It says a lot that a show about anthropomorphized animals was the one that felt most real.
You forget that you're watching wolves, rabbits, deers, and Metal Gear Panda.
In fact, their animalistic characteristics are able to emphasize emotion in a way
that makes them seem even more eerily...
human.
And I can't wait to see what the story will have to offer in season 2 and hopefully beyond.
Basically, in a nutshell, I watched Beastars, and I'm still not a furry...
BUUUUUU-
*clicks tongue* No.
Well...
Normally in the year of anime we get to see some high-octane, hard-hitting shows.
So with that in mind,
what did 2019 offer us?
♫ Roller Mobster - Carpenter Brut ♫
Yeah, this year was kind of dry as a whole.
For real though, 2019 was one of THE MOST action-packed years in recent memory,
with old and new franchises not only continuing the expected hype,
but a lot of the times reaching their absolute peak.
Demon Slayer blew up the entire community in a single episode,
Mob Psycho 100 showcased some of the most impressive fight sequences I've ever seen,
Attack on Titan topped IMDB's chart for the highest-rated episode of any series of all time,
and My Hero Academia did an excellent job at
coloring in some manga panels.
(They totally made up for it later though.)
There are several anime of the year contenders right here, and most of them could have easily won
if they had aired in any other year, so this is going to be a pretty long segment.
Let's start with Mob.
The first season of Mob always felt like it was living in the shadow of One Punch Man,
but this was the season it truly grew into its own, and maybe even surpassed its older cousin.
What I expected was more great action,
more great animation like the first season,
and it delivered that, then exceeded it.
Fight after fight after amazing fight, it was an absolute spectacle,
with the group battle against the teleporting psychic being one of the coolest sequences I've ever seen.
But what I didn't expect was how much heart it would have as well.
The character writing between Mob and Reigen was phenomenal,
and the unexpected character development they saw, and teary moments in the season,
sucker-punched me way harder than any of the fights.
It grew from this flashy, funny action series to something so much more.
It was hype. It was emotional. It was touching.
It was just the complete package.
After it finished, I didn't think anything could come close to Mob this year,
and then Attack on Titan must have heard that and was like,
"Yo..."
"Hold my kidnapped Eren."
Attack on Titan
Attack on Titan Season 3
Attack on Titan Season 3 Part 2
Attack on Titan Season 3 Part 2 Half-Life 3
Platform 9 3/4
was the perfect payoff to everything the series had been building up so far.
The legacy of one of the most hyped franchises to rise up in the past decade had finally reached that hype,
then punched straight past it.
Seeing the evolution of the series go from thrill ride to mystery to political thriller
to the culmination of all of this was an absolute joy to experience.
The mixture of a fully developed cast we were all invested in being put into a high-stakes situation,
where you genuinely did not know what was going to happen,
resulted in a dramatic, tense, action-packed,
edge-of-your-seat experience
that delivered some of the most compelling entertainment you can find anywhere this year,
anime or not.
It's also one of the few series that has built up this massive mystery,
and actually delivered a satisfying answer.
From what I've heard, the events of Season 4 are going to surpass even this, so I am absolutely hyped.
I cannot wait to properly experience it for the first time over the coming year the only way I know how to:
through
dipshit manga readers who can't resist posting spoilers in the comments section.
And then Vinland Saga finally broke the curse of a highly-acclaimed, historical seinen manga
getting an actual decent anime adaptation.
I originally thought that if Vinland Saga were to ever get an anime,
all it would need to do is to animate the manga in a competent fashion,
and it would be a contender for anime of the year,
and that's exactly what happened.
The tale of viking Sasuke on his lone quest to
OK BOOMER
everything his dad tried to teach him
and Aske-chad trying to set the world record for longest
father-killing kill streak in history is one that will stick with me for a very long time.
While it may not be as loud or in-your-face as some of the other shows here,
it hits just as hard or maybe even more so.
This is gonna go down as a special series and with the ending it gave, it was the perfect way to cap off the year.
My Hero Academia has pretty much continued being
My Hero Academia.
Me and the boys continued our trip across Italy in
(Google translate's American accent)
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure Golden Wind
(Google translates poor excuse of an Italian accent)
♫ Funiculì, Funiculà - Luigi Denza ♫
Yes, JoJo Part 5 continued in a season where Italy itself became a JoJo reference,
as anime watchers finally understood the pain of the question,
(African accent)
"How the fuck does King Crimson work?"
Fans were finally rewarded with many highly anticipated moments
including the animated seven page muda that was a glorious moment
(Dio's sad yet proud wryyy in the background)
any father would be proud of.
Next up is
*Cocking gun SFX*
Meg: "Oh my god the fire's got a gun!"
*Bang*
Louis: "What the fuck was that?"
♫ Inferno - Mrs. Green Apple ♫
Fire Force took the phrase "Fighting fire with fire" to whole new heights
as David Production finally got a chance to flex their animation muscles outside of JoJo,
giving us a show with several choices of amazing top tier waifus
and Tamaki.
Yeah I said it, Tamaki fans.
What are you gonna do?
Trip over and land on my dick?
Look, I'm a degenerate that lives for trashy fanservice,
but there's a time and a place for that and I don't need it breaking all the immersion
of every serious action scene she's in.
Finally, of course, there was Demon Slayer, which was undoubtedly the new breakout hit this year.
I can't remember the last time I saw such an instant explosion from just a single episode.
See, there was Demon Slayer before episode 19
and then there was Demon Slayer AFTER episode 19.
It went from this moderately popular action show to the hip trending topic on Twitter.
Everyone started watching it, and then Ninja tweeted that it was gonna become the greatest anime of all time
and everyone was like,
"Well, I mean, he's pretty good at Fortnite."
"So he's probably right."
*Frolic begins playing*
Not to take anything away from the scene, as I do think it was one of the most beautifully crafted moments
I've seen in any shown in any shounen.
I mean I kind of called it a work of art.
And it is a really good show but I think as a whole it's a bit premature,
because the story only just feels like it's truly started to get going,
and its competition this year are shows that have reached their narrative peaks.
What I find more interesting is how after all these years we've kind of got a big three again.
With One Piece staying where it is,
Naruto being replaced by green Naruto,
some people could even argue that Demon Slayer has just filled that gap for the new generation's Bleach.
*clears throat*
*clicks tongue*
But I'm not gonna be the one to start that shitstorm of a conversation.
Before I get to my anime of the year,
there are a few more shows that didn't really belong to any of these categories
but definitely shouldn't be left out.
Promised Neverland was an engrossing thriller about a group of children
breaking out of an extremely secure locked down facility,
overlooked by highly intelligent monsters...
by playing tag.
This was some of the most gripping anime you could find this year.
Aside from having a completely unique premise,
the cat-and-mouse game manages to deliver a story with so many twists and turns
without ever feeling like they were forcing it.
It builds up tension beautifully and it's one of those cliffhanger shows that will have you
clicking on the next episode
faster than you could say
ITADAKIMAAASU!!
Gordon: "Finally,"
"some good fucking food."
If I had any small issues with it, is that it pushed my suspension of disbelief to the fucking limit.
Like I know these kids are meant to be smart,
but when they started playing 5D intergalactic mind games
and had already strategized their highly elaborate escape plan
from the moment they were fucking conceived,
all while masking it as a children's game,
I was like,
"I don't know if these kids could be going THAT far."
♫ Moon Men (Instrumental) - Jake Chudnow ♫
Or can they?
And if we're still nitpicking, there something a bit off about how the characters were drawn,
but I couldn't quite put my finger on it.
"Did he just say there was something off about the way we look?"
"Yeah, I think he did just say that."
"I don't think there's anything weird about my face. I have a normal face!"
"No, you look perfectly normal."
"What do you think Ray?"
"Yeah, I have no idea what the hell he's talking about."
Meanwhile, in Dr. Stone character designs...
(Radio static communication)
"Suffix zero six, we are approaching runway one-niner are we clear to land? Over."
"Suffix zero six, you are number one for runway one-niner, you are clear to land whenever you are ready. Over."
"Suffix zero six, thank you very much, taking it down now."
*Airplane approaches runway*
*Airplane has now landed*
It's time
to d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-
Dr. Stone this year gave us a long-awaited anime adaptation of
those two Indian guys building huts on YouTube that somehow got recommended to you at 1 a.m.
And I'll be honest, this show left me a bit conflicted in the end.
On one hand, it's one of the most interesting premises out there,
and seeing the process of how they make advanced technology with the most primitive of tools
was some of the most entertaining things you can find in anime all year.
But on the other hand,
I could give less a shit about any of the conflicts here.
Look, I really don't care that Tsukasa hates boomers.
Anytime there was a contractually obligated Shounen Jump fight,
I couldn't help but just wanna go back to seeing the villagers
pissing themselves at the sight of Senku making glass.
It's probably the first time in my life when I've seen a tournament arc and I've been like,
"Oh."
"They're putting in a tournament arc."
*yaaawwwwnn*
*That sound you make when you wake up while drooling*
"Yeah,"
"wake me up when something interesting happen-"
*Awe-inspired gasp*
"LIGHHHT BULLB
AAAAARRRRRRRR--"
No Guns Life almost single-handedly tried keeping the cyberpunk genre alive along with Psycho-Pass,
giving us an old-school hard-boiled detective story that unfortunately got looked over by a lot of people,
probably because its name wasn't something hip and catchy enough like,
That Time Alphonse Elric Got Reincarnated As A Gun.
Dororo was a legitimately good remake of a samurai anime from the 60s
that hardly anyone watched because it was an Amazon Prime exclusive,
and the only way I see people still remembering the show is when they ask Amazon,
"Hey Amazon."
"Do you have Demon Slayer on Amazon Prime?"
and Amazon's like,
"Oh, yeah, we have Demon Slayer on Amazon Prime"
and this is their Demon Slayer on Amazon Prime.
Hoshiai no Sora was a really promising anime original sports drama whose production just got
axed halfway through leaving us once again with just
half an anime.
Fate is still making more money than they know how to spend.
Babylon was a great show that I apparently missed.
Umm.
*weird gasp*
Let's see. Was there anything else I left out?
*A sound I don't want to hear again or ever describe*
*A sexual ass moan*
Yeah, I think that's everything.
This year was honestly the hardest year to pick my anime of the year for a very long time.
I praise 2018 for the sheer volume of good shows but, 2019 has seemingly matched that
while still producing a handful of shows that were even better than anything that came out the year before.
Many of these shows would have been an easy shoo-in if they literally aired in any other year.
It was a tough choice,
but after dwelling on it for a week or two,
I've got to give it to...
*Drumroll*
Vinland Saga.
I've said previously that every so often you come across a work of fiction like Vinland Saga,
something that exudes this sense of unquantifiable greatness,
and there is a word that personifies what I'm talking about...
a masterpiece.
To me, Vinland Saga is a tale that earnestly earns that title.
Mob might have been better animated,
Attack on Titan might have been more compelling,
Demon Slayer might have been more hype,
Beastars might have been more unique,
but I know the tale told in Vinland Saga will stick with me for much longer.
I mean, it already has, this isn't the first time I've got to experience this story,
but that didn't make it hit any less hard.
It's a story that's powerful and raw,
brutal and grim,
yet, somehow it's...
beautiful.
Culminating in one of the greatest climaxes anime has ever seen.
The series displays some of the best character writing and developments you could find in its diverse cast,
but even so there was still one clear standout,
because 2019 was the year of Askeladd.
Askeladd isn't just the antagonist of the year.
Askeladd is the character of the year and a contender for the whole decade.
It's not often you come across this multifaceted character,
who is not only compelling to watch but commands your attention every second he's on screen,
exuding the type of charisma that doesn't just charm the people in the story,
but yourself as well.
It says a lot that a character you end up cheering for,
laughing for,
crying for,
is this manipulative scheming bastard
who is responsible for killing hundreds of people,
innocent or not,
and personally ruined God knows how many more lives.
Every fiber of your being tells you that you should hate this man
and you end up just loving him.
Some people try living as a hero,
only to see themselves becoming the villain.
But, here was a man who chose to live as the villain
who we all saw
became...
a hero.
This was the final series I finished before the year ended
and I can't think of a better way to cap off a fantastic year
for anime.
*Giorno's theme kicks in*
So as 2020 now has fully come,
one last time,
let's give it up
for 2019.
*Montage set to Giorno's theme*
Bucciarati: "Arrivederci."
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed that video.
I just want to give a quick thanks and shout out to Book Walker today for sponsoring me.
A lot of the titles that I've talked about today are available in their store
in both manga and light novel form.
In fact, they've made a link with all of the available titles that are on their store that I've also talked about today.
And this also does include the title I chose for anime of the year, Vinland Saga,
and also a lot of the other contenders, and most of the isekai.
You can find all of that by clicking on the link in the description, and don't forget that you can
use coupon code "GIGGUK" for five dollars off.
And with that said, thank you very much to:
Jared Norris
Sallem Abdullah
Domixspietato
Bddinyolife
Walt-O
Basel
And everyone else on Patreon for helping to support me on this month.
Now if you watched the end of my last video you'd know that I said that I wouldn't be making a "Year in __" video
unless I could put all of myself into it and
*inhales*
Well, that's why it's a bit like this year.
I hope the wait was worth it because I'm really proud of it, and it was a hell of a lot of work,
but it was actually really nice to work on it this year
and really being more relaxed and not so pressured to finish it on the New Year's.
Well, I mean this video's late if you've just been watching me for the past few years.
But if you're an OG watcher I mean,
this is just back to the norm right?
Hehehe
*pained laughter*
As this is my first video of the new years,
I just wanted to thank all of you who supported me in 2019
and I hope I can continue making content that you enjoy throughout this entire next year!
Anyway, I hope 2020 has treated you well so far.
I've been Gigguk and I will see you all,
next time.